[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans le château de
caddie avec ce matin gabriel jean marie
bonjour bonjour vous êtes membre
dirigeant de combat ouvrier un parti
politique communiste révolutionnaire
d'inspiration trotskiste et en ce moment
gabriel jean marie on est dans une
période de commémoration d'abord
commémoration des 60 ans de la fusillade
sanglante de la grève des ouvriers de la
canne au lamentin on va pas y revenir ce
matin on en a parlé longuement hier avec
l'historien gilbert pago et puis c'est
également la commémoration des 150 ans
de la commune de paris
combat ouvrier en fait notamment un
sujet dans son journal
et puis vous avez organisé une
conférence de presse cette semaine vous
organisez des réunions autour de cette
commémoration des 150 ans de la commune
de paris une expérience de gouvernement
par une partie du prolétariat français
mais qui a certes duré pas très
longtemps
quelques semaines et qui a durablement
marqué les esprits et cette expérience
de gouvernement a été réprimée dans le
sang
la fureur la déportation par par l'armée
et le pouvoir politique d'alors d'abord
signalé qu'il n'y avait pas que des
ouvriers peut-être justement c'était une
insurrection populaire que cette commune
de paris c'est une action populaire il
n'y avait pas que des ouvriers y avait
aussi des petits artisans des petits
sans grades des laissés pour compte et
alors vous avez dit quelque chose
monsieur carrus vous avez dit qui a
marqué les esprits pas seulement les
esprits ça marquait beaucoup
l'expérience n'a duré que 72 jours mais
l'expérience a été un labo à 3 alors
vous vous dites que c'est une expérience
riche d'enseignements y compris en 2021
il collectionne 2021 alors je vais
l'aborder ou quelque chose c'est que
dans l'histoire de l'humanité cent
cinquante ans c'était il ya quelques
secondes
donc c'est ça s'est passé hier 150 ans
ça s'est passé
ç'a permis de montrer que ce qu'on
pensait être impossible était possible
et la juste avant je vous ai remis par
exemple un certain nombre de mesures
d'urgence prises par les les communards
c'était possible c'était possible et
aujourd'hui plus encore que hier c'est
possible alors on pourra pas parce que
j'en à une vingtaine on pourra pas tout
détailler mais pour vous qu'est-ce qui
est ce qui est important par exemple de
retenir de toutes ces mesures d'urgence
qui avait été adopté alors qu'ils
visaient à améliorer les conditions
d'existence des travailleurs absolument
alors je vois en choisir deux ou trois
mais par exemple réquisition des
logements vacants pour les sinistrés par
exemple abaissement du temps de travail
10 heures au lieu de 12 à 17 heures par
jour par exemple interdiction du travail
de nuit pour les enfants et pour les
femmes par exemple création
d'orphelinats par exemple interdiction
de l'enseignement religieux par exemple
séparation de l'église et de l'état
par exemple égalité des salaires entre
les hommes et les femmes mais on
pourrait citer on pourrait citer et ça
s'est fait en 72 jours alors 72 c'est
peu mais je le répète ça a été un
laboratoire et c'est cette expérience
qui a permis la révolution de 1905 en
russie ce que dit lénine trotsky ont
appelé une répétition et qui a permis
par la suite à révolution de 1917 qui a
duré six ans on nous dira oui mais ça
n'a pas tenu
ben vous savez c'est 100 laboratoires
mais quels enseignements pour
aujourd'hui
ben pour aujourd'hui alors
l'enseignement principal c'est que faut
partir de ce de la manière dont ça s'est
terminé il ya eu la semaine sanglante
tiers et c'est qu'on pense ont écrasé
dans le sang des gens et effectué les
premiers
trop de vitesse le diable que l'on
allait devenir celui qui avait pris le
relais de napoléon bonaparte
3 après donc fait de la france à
l'approché d'un an qu'ils ont écrasée
dans le sang
ils ont fusillé ils ont exterminé et
l'histoire du drapeau rouge
on vous dit que par exemple la scène
était rouge donc ils ont fait ça alors
pourquoi l'enseignement principal qu'il
faut tirer c'est que pour conquérir le
pouvoir et pour le garder ben ils font
un outil et cet outil ça s'appelle un
parti parti faut une organisation faut
des militants mais il faut des gens font
des travailleurs qu'ils soient sur leurs
affaires
parce que quand on n'est pas organisé
comme ceux d'en face
quand on ne on a pas une organisation
stricte
ben on se fait avoir c'est ce qu'il
fallait faire et on le paye trafic
alors on va parler de ce qui se passe en
ce moment puisque les ouvriers les
artisans les petits commerçants
évidemment pas eu seulement ni
exclusivement mais c'est eux qui sont
confrontées qui peut-être paye le plus
lourd tribut aux conséquences de la
crise qu vide et dans un combat ouvrier
vous jetez évidemment un regard
là-dessus c'est même l'objet de de
l'éditorial du dernier numéro que j'ai
consultés évidemment avant de cet
entretien quoi et donc à propos de la
situation de à l'est pour aller vite et
schématiser de la classe ouvrière ou des
classes populaires face à la crise qu
vide et ses conséquences alors eux en
posant la question vous avez dit
peut-être on va enlever le peut-être ce
sont ceux là qui paye le plus lourd
tribut
y'a pas de peut-être et il suffit
d'écouter un petit peu toutes les
mesures prises par le gouvernement mais
aussi au niveau de la ctm ici et par
tous ceux qui interviennent
il ya eu comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire ailleurs c'était open bar pour les
des carpes les patrons les capitalistes
et je me souviens même de l'interview
d'une cadre de la chambre de commerce
qui disait en substance
mais messieurs messieurs messieurs
mesdames messieurs précipitez-vous il ya
de l'argent à prendre je peux vous
pensez que pour certains chefs
d'entreprise à écouter certains on n'a
pas de pouvoir economics il ya une
aubaine l'a en quelque sorte monsieur
carrus ce virus je ne dirais pas que
c'est eux qui l'ont envoyé mais ça a été
une formidable aubaine revenir sur des
cons qui de l'argent qu'on ne trouvait
pas avant qui coule à flots jusqu'à
maintenant d'ailleurs des licenciements
des restrictions non monsieur cas où ça
est une formidable aubaine et ça
continue ça continue donc hommes oui
effectivement ce sont les petits qui
vont trinquer et qui continuent de
traquer parce que la situation est ce
qu'elle est et que ceux qui
interviennent et elles viennent d'abord
pour ceux qui possèdent
c'est comme ça le télétravail fait de
plus en plus à de plus en plus une part
importante dans ce contexte justement de
de crise où il faut limiter les contacts
les rassemblements nombreux et le monde
du travail y est confond confronté aussi
le télétravail pour vous c'est une bonne
chose à combat ouvrier alors je veux
dire le télétravail c'est une bonne
chose surtout par les employeurs moi je
suis un enseignant alors autres étaient
certes mais je me souviendrai toujours
vous avez reçu sur ce plateau c'était le
15 juin la numéro 2 du rectorat et la
vente par ailleurs une expression
enseignement hybride nouvelles modalités
d'enseignement et certains n'avaient pas
toujours compris ce que ça voulait dire
mais ça veut dire tout simplement que
c'est une opportunité formidable là
encore pour réduire sur les moyens
réduits sur les personnels que pour les
employés non et pour les employés je
vais vous dire par exemple il ya une
grosse polémique
faut-il donne mais les tickets
restaurants aux employés qui sont en
télétravail
ah ben voilà ça fait un trafic sera
versée à mais c'est très pratique
vous savez moi je me souviens j'ai un
cousin qui vit en france qui est dans
l'informatique un bain l'entreprise a
vendu tous pratiquement tous les locaux
et le premier qui arrive trouve un point
pour travailler sinon le mélo bureaux se
trouvent à la maison c'est une
opportunité formidable je vous dis et ce
sont les travailleurs qui payent qui
trinquent
donc faut y regarder à deux fois
ils se regardent et a23 donne absolument
puisque c'est dans longtemps une fois ça
a été le moyen de revenir de réduire sur
des ceux des camps qui autre sujet
d'actualité
chez nous en martinique se sont laissé
le collectif des ouvriers et ouvrières
agricoles empoisonné par les pesticides
qui demande réparation à hauteur du
préjudice subi
notamment sur le plan de la santé il y à
une manifestation nouvelle manifestation
qui est prévue ce week-end est ce que
vous êtes de ce combat là aussi
justement à combat ouvrier quand on
porte ce nom là ne sommes plus que
jamais et nous sommes à fond dans ce
combat là qu'on me permette de dire
quand même avancé quand même curieux les
empoisonneurs sont tranquilles ils sont
protégés
il y avait une formule 1 selon que vous
serez ceci cela bon selon que vous serez
empoisonneurs ou pas vous serez
persécutés au vous serez protégé c'est
exactement ce que fait la justice
ça fait plus de 14 précise jean la dame
tranquille tranquille et l'état bien
organisé poursuit enfin le principal
intéressé nous dit on et n'est plus de
ce monde à celui qui l'emmènera mais
n'en faisait partie des traditions
importées focalise pas sur une personne
je me focalise sur une classe swing
catégories d'accords bien et l'état
poursuit ceux qui dénoncent ce qu'ils
dénoncent l'inertie le silence de l'état
comment peut-on le qualifier alors oui
effectivement nous nous sommes engagés
là dedans
nous soutenons nous soutenons la
manifestation donc de 27
nous appelons massivement la population
à participer à celle du 10 avril
jusqu'à ce que effectivement justice
soit rendue justice dans le sens les
pollueurs payeurs y compris y compris un
profit ce camp toute cette fortune faite
sur le dos des malheureux qui recense 25
et allait il nous faut conclure gabriel
jean marie de combat ouvrier membres de
combat ouvrier
bientôt les élections à la ctm alors on
peut peut-être en
main ou un peu plus tard dans l'année si
c'est la crise sanitaire perdure dans
les mêmes conditions actuelles mais donc
il est prévu des élections vous comptez
participer vous allez souvent aux
élections alors c'est vrai que ça se
solde pas par beaucoup de voix mais pour
vous là n'est pas l'essentiel
nous saisirons toutes les occasions pour
pouvoir pour permettre aux travailleurs
d'exprimer leurs idées
nous saisirons toutes les occasions pour
dénoncer ce système
donc vous serez de ce qui sort de cette
campagne électorale est dors et déjà
nous appelons les travailleurs à lorsque
nous les solliciteront à être candidats
à participer activement
parce que ça n'est pas le biais par le
biais d'une élection qu'on va changer la
face du monde mais je reviens à notre
sujet de départ
qu'on pense à la commune de paris
récompense à la révolution de 17 c'est
ainsi qu'on peut changer la face du
monde
merci gabriel jean marie d'avoir été
notre invité ce matin bonne journée
merci
[Musique]